- God saves the Queen.
- La reine Élisabeth II a passé
sa vie en représentation
et devant les caméras.
Pourtant, à bien des égards,
elle reste mystérieuse
et énigmatique.
Le réalisateur britannique
Roger Michell, à qui on doit
le film "Coup de foudre
à Notting Hill", a plongé
dans llilililiers d'heures
d'archives publiques et privées
de la souveraine pour assembler
un portrait en pièces détachées.
- Ow! It's my foot
you're standing on.
- Le résultat est
un documentaire décalé,
sans narration, qui ne ressemble
à rien de ce qui a itititit
sur la reine et qui la révèle
sous un nouveau jour.
MARC LAURENDEAU, journaliste
- Elle a l'air d'une étudi
quand elle est jeune, même jeune
reine. Plus le temps avance,
plus elle devient zen, grave,
retenue. Alors, on voit cette
évolution, c'est-à-dire que
c'est une femme qui est un peui.
- We grew up loving the Queen.
To us, teenagers,
she was a babe!
- Le film "Elizabeth :
Regard(s) singulier(s)"
enchaîne et entrecroise des
moments de la vie de la reine
captés en vidéo, classés
par chapitres, de sa passion
pour les chevaux aux drames
qu'elle a dû affront
en passant par le poids écrasant
de la couronne.
- It weighs a ton.
You can't look down because if
you did, your neck would break.
- Des images royales,
toutes plus exceptionnelles et
surréalistes les unes que les
autres, eseseseses côte à côte,
tracent un portrait singulier
de cette femme de devoir.
- Moi, j'ai beaucoup aimé.
Oui, vraiment, c'est surprenant,
créatif, insolite. Surréaliste,
mais le surréalisme
a du bon au cinéma.
- I think everybody
really will concede on this
of all days.
- Le résultat est irré
mais respectueux. Le fait de
rester à la surface en reprenant
uniquement des images existantes
permet de jeter un regard
différent sur sa vie
et son destin exceptionnel.
- Does she fell like
your mother, grandmother
- Yes, yes.
- Alors que la reine s'apprête à
célébrer son jubilé de platine,
le film "Elizabeth : Regard(s)
singulier(s)" permet de prendre
pleinement conscience que
cette femme de 96 ans a été
témoin et actrice privilégiéeles
qui ont transformé le monde
au cours du dernier siècle.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Can